my name is Ming Liu my name is danica
yes my name is Francisco Rodriguez we're
all from Warren our talk is translating
wolf marfa into more languages
it's about localization of wolf larvae
the computational knowledge engine so
just a little bit introduction to
Wolfram Alpha itself Wolfram Alpha is
wolf ins unique system for computing
answers and providing knowledge and we
call that computational knowledge engine
and the primary product form is the
public website wolframalpha.com it's
released in 2009 about a decade ago and
it has become one of the most popular
wolfram products the goal of Wolfram
Alpha is making the world's knowledge
computable just some words about
computational knowledge engine it can be
logically separated into four parts or
layers the natural language interface as
that allows questions and queries to be
given in natural language but so far
only in English and we have the
foundation of systematic curated data
that has trillions of pieces of data in
over a thousand different knowledge
domains we have different types of data
but the textual data is almost always in
English and also sometimes the data
source we use for constructing the
knowledge base is English language
english language only in the US primary
for example the flights if you were to
ask flights over some city in other
countries it'll just say data not
available computational intelligence
that's essentially the domain expertise
that's built into the system as
automated methods for solving problems
and deriving information from data and
at the end at the top level we have
dynamic presentation of the knowledge it
computes so that includes the formatting
of results summaries and visualizations
that of course it's all in English and
also the design could be English
language or us oriented that said at the
real implementation or code level all
the four components can be mixed so that
let that leads us to the localization of
war from Martha so on one side
WolframAlpha has an ever-expanding
coverage of knowledge domains and
increasing ability to answer questions
there's a totally different dimension to
grow this is we should extend the
natural language interface and the
presentation of knowledge into other
languages and also broaden the user user
base and the content coverage into other
languages and regions so if the goal of
what Martha is making the world's
knowledge computable the localized the
WolframAlpha is to make this operation
more accessible and internationally our
of 1.0 release goal is to make all the
mass related features localized into six
different languages Japanese Spanish
Chinese Korean French and Russian so
here is to show you some example outputs
I think I will let ya
so here we have some outputs on how this
will eventually look in the web so right
now this is still under development we
have the the internal internal pages for
these development pages and in general
as you can see we are trying to
translate everything that is text into a
language and not only the text but also
some conventions for example as you can
see in Spanish in French and in other
languages we use a decimal separator the
comma instead of the point so we should
also change that in the output in the
graphics you might see that and so every
piece of text should be localized in the
right language here is an example of
folder we already have all these
languages working somehow not all the
domains because this is a project
ongoing but we have many examples that
we can show
so in general this this project work
well requires many many steps that we
are going to explain so we will spend
the next few slides trying to explain
why localization is important so if you
look at how many languages are there in
the whole world
there are over seven thousand but only
twenty five has more than 50 million
speaker population and 15 million is
about 0.6 percent of the world's
population so only these 25 and it's
visualized in this plot so all the rest
of the languages is in this small corner
and here are the largest ones and we are
currently working on the following six
languages
adding the existing English that's the
highlighted part and that's
approximately excluding English a struct
proximally one third of the world's
population yes and if we think about the
your graphical coverage of Warren Alpha
right now with English we are covering
this area but with the new languages we
are going to cover a lot more so we are
going to have presence in all the
continents with these six new languages
with everything together we might cover
most of the war graphically speaking so
this this is the a good motivation to
start this project of course most of
America a lot of Africa and well Europe
is very diverse so we are starting the
just
so this is a time series chart for false
refraction and now average query ranks
and then
query fraction with known ASCII
characters the first one is a forceful
fraction rate also means a whole
fraction means percentage of queries not
answered so as you can see the the two
to three months after the release we
have not really good rate but what from
alpha is updating weekly so it's getting
better and better better and then
recently we have just more like 5%
fourth rate and then the average query
rings we got like 15 to 12
Thanks clearly we got the first around
the resistance and then it's getting
longer and larger and the recent we get
more complicated longer query we get and
then the last one is a query fraction
with no ASCII characters it's a weekly
average but the so it's anyway it's
getting increasing the number of non
ASCII characters we yeah yes non-ascii
cockers or use a view of how many people
is trying to write something in
non-english so still there is like a 5%
of people that is writing scenes that is
not in English so that's why we should
try to answer them and also another view
of why we need this is for example this
is the traffic that we get by browser
language when you have your properly
setup your your computer you usually put
I speaking Spanish I have my my fire
focusing in Spanish I have my navigator
in German in Russian etc and this is
what we get from the stats so the second
language that has more hits in wolf
Renato right now is for example Spanish
I have here involved the ones that we
have chosen for now so still we have 70%
of
English speakers that is trying to use
alphabet we want to increase these other
numbers so that's part of this
motivation to a start this project okay
so then we will spend a few more
flawless
slides on the development actual
development so some basic facts first
the team is consists of translators data
curators developers testers that many of
which are language natives and overall
there are tars and dozens of people
that's involved to different degrees so
localize the WolframAlpha is built on
top of the regular english language
english language or from martha and
that's the features is inherited into
the localize to build so the
localization happens to the selected
components gradually with the original
behavior as fallback on the input on the
input side you can still ask those
queries in English then the rest of
features well basically the rest
features you can still prairie normally
in English and if it's localized you can
query them in both English and the
localization language on the output side
it's the same until it's fully localized
it can show up as a mixture of localized
plus English so the next is the
different components that we work on for
localization the largest components in
terms of the actual new data points or
lines of code that get created is the
curated data and there are two places
where this happened one is there's a
huge set of source files so these are
just nested lists of basically key and
value pairs these get translated and
distort back into the files and the
other big part is in the
database which translate it and it's
merged with the existing data besides
data there is also a lot of work to do
with the source code itself so one big
part of that is grammar rule so there is
just there is a grammar rule symbol in
the language itself and we have
something similar in the Wolfram Alpha
system also on the output side there are
a lot of code that constructs
results summaries visualizations many of
which requires refactoring yeah so one
big part of doing this is trying to
extract the these text that's for
display but it's all mixed in some
computational logic that's you know
doing some language independent things
but it's all mixed so the first step is
to extract them then we store them in a
separate database along with these
curated translations so this is just
some small small part of that the actual
translations we do we will do some
machine translation first but we found
that has some limited use only because
the fraction of poor translation is
really high many of these has to do with
some proper nouns or some technical
terms it's not translated in the correct
context it's often too literal in some
cases we do we use machine translation
machine translations as the first to
draft before manual curation and
proofreading we also use data sources
like Wikipedia and the wiki data to to
translate the the named entities like
chemical elements cities for example 20%
of all the city names can be translated
this way into job
there are also some some other
miscellaneous tasks that's related to
translation for example in Chinese there
is because the words in Chinese they are
not separated by white space so we can
do something to separate this then turn
them into linguistics patterns that's
used for understanding the queries and
this is one example so we use
Mathematica notebooks to carry out the
actual translation and data curation so
this is one example of such notebook
this happens to be one for translating
units we have the original English name
the translated name and these are the
patterns or alternative names for these
units and also some reference links to
external sites okay so that's the
regular workflow but we also encountered
some challenges so this is the most
obvious one is that we have huge amount
of data and the source files or code to
localize we have about approach in 10000
relational database tables and over a
million names and descriptions of
entities and properties units and on the
input on the parsing side we have
linguist linguistic patterns so the
smallest unit is the what we call token
what we call token basically they are
the semantic constituents in the query
that all have to have some patterns to
match with so that's 10 to the seventh
we also have a higher level saying
called grammar rules that's approaching
10 to the force for sauce code we have a
10 to the 5 10 to the 5 sauce files
10 to the 7th length of sauce code all
of these can have this mixture of data
and logic so that's really a lot of data
and code to look at on the other side
these data are they are not they're
heterogeneous in the way that they are
scattered all over in files and in
databases and also it's mixed data and
the logic for doing computing it's mixed
when you have so much data that you
naturally you want to divide and conquer
but there are many different ways to do
this sometimes you want to divide it by
the content domains sometimes by the
user visible features the two are not
the same they are like like the domain
and range of some function that they
cross over so another important thing to
realize is that Wolfram arthas outputs
they are not static they are all
dynamically generated so as a
consequence of that first the source
code themselves requires localization
and until you have everything localized
you may not really realize the output is
broken you have some partially down
localization then you the output will
show you that you need to do more also
you know I think I'm going to skip all
the details right so yeah so as you know
the consequence of all of this is that
it's hard to measure the overall
completeness because Wolfram Alpha is
always growing so it's almost impossible
to
say it's all done okay so one big part
of our work is to do the refactoring of
the code and our code base is almost a
decade out so there are a lot of legacy
code so localization partly takes care
of housekeeping the original
implementation are often mixture of data
computation styling they are not
logically separated so you know we just
review these code trying to separate
these two examples one is you know
ordinal form we used to have this
function that turns integer into these
ordinal numbers and there are there
turns out there are many many different
implementations and inconsistent usage
so 10 lines of original code turns into
150 in order to support you know six
more languages
another thing that's used very
frequently is we turned the original
perhaps it's just joining parts together
we turn that into a template so this
template itself can be translated into
different languages these variables will
be evaluated when the system is running
so also Wolfram Alpha is released weekly
so the content own content data and
source code they get hundreds of changes
daily so it's very hard to keep
everything consistent yeah and so also
we had many languages and that's a part
of the what we have to to do so for
example we have issues with with grammar
conventions of each language also with
writing scripts so the
factors for example in in the girlfriend
language are only supported up to
playing zero and in some languages we
have they need now of using more than
playing zero for example for the element
names in Chinese also there are things
that we have added in the language
itself because it was nyet for for alpha
for example they extend the support for
functions like to lowercase etc that was
not properly done before for example for
sorry Cyrillic and all these has been
incorporated also in to work on language
also another challenge we had is the
usage of of the files because the files
are encoded in in Mathematica encoding
and it's not very nice to look at them
in order let's say more common developer
tools like even water and water range
doesn't display properly the special
character from warfarin language so this
is what we will see in one case and in
the Mathematica front-end we can see the
proper characters but we need to handle
both because we have tools also for
doing for example the teeth of the files
etc and there are some tools in in that
art has been made in in one language to
handle that but anyway it's hard to mix
all these and allow the status we are
planning that the first release will be
initially of Japanese and Spanish most
only the maps related stuff right now
the overall progress is around 51% but
Counting for all the languages of course
Japanese and Spanish are a bit more
advanced than other languages but we
still are we are really working Chinese
French Korean and Russian so so all this
is coming and well we want to thank the
team of the validation we have a huge
team with we cannot put all the names
there but this is a picture we took
taking
a few days ago taking the opportunity
many of us which work remote are in town
so well that's it for now I don't know
if you have any questions
[Music]
[Applause]